now rising food prices forcing many
shoppers to seek out bargains to fill
their carts good friday evening to you
thanks for staying with us at 6 30 i'm
bryan loftis and i'm christian casa that
is from mead and chicken to eggs and
even vegetables valley residents are
doing what they can to save a buck
milk prices tortilla prices
bacon exactly but yeah we noticed our
bill quite an increase
in pricing it's a harsh reality robert
gonzalez and his family are facing they
are on a fixed income and high food
costs are forcing them to scale back
we're having to cut down on some items
now
what we're doing we're just eating
smaller portions everybody knew that
inflation was coming and of course with
all the stimulus that's been pumped in
the economy because of covid we're
seeing that that inflation is finally
taking effect according to the u.s
bureau of labor statistics fish chicken
and meat prices spiking 12.5 percent
from last year financial planner mel o
says consumers shouldn't expect relief
anytime soon there is talk about
inflation potentially
slowing down the fed is going to has
said that they are planning on taking
action in march until then shoppers like
marianne allen are left finding ways to
get more for their buck everybody you
know look for coupons that you've got or
match-ups you can do
there's more than just the the
manufacturers
and the store coupons which often can be
used together allen adds planning ahead
on sales and coupons has saved her up to
75 percent off her grocery bill i'm glad
they were
special
because i was going to get a bigger bag
but that's all i had the money for
well remember there are apps like ibotta
fetch and swag box that can help you
score the best deal also be on the
lookout for new items because
manufacturers tend to offer deals for
you to try them